if you've ever found yourself tossing
and turning on a sweltering summer night
then you know how crucial role
temperature plays in a good night's
sleep
under normal conditions our body's core
temperature drops from ninety eight
point nine down to ninety seven point
seven degrees right when we're about to
fall through it remains low throughout
the night and rises again just before we
awake but when environmental temperature
rises the body is prevented from
shedding heat which results in poorer
sleep
so if environmental temperature can
interrupt the normal sleep cycle
how might climate change affect us which
will give us hotter nights and cause
wide unexpected swings in temperature
researchers looked at sleep data from
seven hundred and sixty-five thousand US
residents between 2002 to 2011
participants were asked how many nights
each month they got a poor night's sleep
the team combined these responses with
data from weather stations across the
country
they look specifically for when nightly
temperatures were hotter than average
from the same time period according to
their analysis changes in weather and
sleep are linked as temperatures rose so
did the number of restlessness
over one month a one degree increase in
nighttime temperature produced an
increase of about three nights of
insufficient sleep per 100 people
applying this across the current
population of the US that's nearly a
hundred and ten million extra nights of
insufficient sleep annually filtering by
seasons the effects were tripled in the
summer time and the groups who were
affected the most were those least able
to cope lower-income respondents and the
elderly now predicting the future is
tricky because changes in technology and
even human behavior are difficult to
account for but if trends continue
researchers predict that climate change
could cause in the u.s. by 2050 six
additional nights a month of
insufficiency per 100 people and by 2099
more than forty nine months of
insufficient sleep per 100 people
these effects may seem trivial compared
to the large-scale impacts of climate
change but consider how important people
to our well-being and that a third of us
already have to put to sleep
even if we find ways to counter these
impacts with medicines or technologies
our sleep could be very different in the
future
[Music]
you
[Music]